ross tucker former nfl offensive lineman
the ross tucker football podcast
westwood one nfl analyst and uh he was
on the call last night
chiefs and the bills he's also got
giants eagles coming up thursday night
and
ross kind enough to get up early for uh
this broadcast
this show and entertain a nation how
were the conditions last night ross
you know dan they weren't that bad uh
but i didn't think we would see the
shootout that we were hoping to see
just because there was like a
significant
missed the whole time and having played
center
and knowing how quarterbacks like to
grip the ball i thought that that might
have
some impact it certainly seemed to have
some impact with josh allen throwing the
ball
there were a few drops i don't know that
it was the biggest reason
that there wasn't as many points as we
thought i think both teams playing a lot
of two deep
safety coverages and trying to keep
everything in front of them
was the biggest reason why it wasn't the
shootout that we thought it could be
but certainly the weather was a factor i
mean you know dan i played three years
in buffalo
it reminded me of pretty much every day
in buffalo ever
josh allen mvp bandwagon there's still
some seats available here what are you
noticing right now with josh allen
well i'm disappointed and i'll tell you
why i'm disappointed
you know i have an affinity for buffalo
played for five teams but that was where
i played the most and all that stuff
and i go on all these radio stations all
around the country for radio.com and
they're always saying
are the bills for real ross or is josh
allen for real i mean
that is i get that every station i go on
and dan the first five weeks four weeks
i said yep
they got a great roster the bill because
you know the way it is they haven't won
a playoff game since 95. so people
are not going to believe both in the
bills
in general and josh allen in particular
until they show it so for a whole month
i told everybody
it's different the bills are for real
and then two standalone prime time games
which are like ten times as important as
a sunday one o'clock game in the court
of public opinion
because everybody's watching everybody's
on twitter
they did not play well josh allen did
not play well i thought he played okay
against the titans
other than the really bad pick to
malcolm butler last night he did not
play well
at all and so everyone that was a
doubter of the bills and josh allen
these last two games they got more than
enough ammunition now dan for the rest
of the year to say nope
that's the guy see i told you josh
allen's still the guy that can't win the
big one
and will make the bad turnover when i
need him to make the play
what stood out last night to me was
we're used to the chiefs being faster
than everybody else
they bullied the bills last night when
you're running the ball like that
that you know having the capability to
be able to load up
uh edward ziller and you don't have to
rely necessarily on
mahomes's arm that how surprised were
you with that game plan with kansas city
and that it was successful
well they had to do and take what the
bills were giving them i mean the bill
this is so i think teams are going to
play the chiefs
because the bill sat with two deep
safeties
the whole game and it's it's like
pounding your head into a wall dan to
try to throw deep against that it's just
not smart
you have an extra blocker they're not
putting the extra guy in the box
so you have to run them out of it you
have to run the football
and to be honest with you dan i think
that the bills
were kind of okay with it they they'd
rather give up
five to seven yards to clyde edwards
hilaire then 57 the tyree kill
at the end of the day even though it
might look bad and be demoralizing
they gave up 26 points and the 26 points
included a couple of unbelievable
catches by travis kelsey
some ridiculous third down conversions
by patrick mahomes so
net net even though the chiefs
controlled the clock i don't think the
bills are that disappointed
in only giving up 26 points because it
took
miraculous mahomes to even get that many
he by the way dan
i and i don't know somebody we need this
might be stat of the day maybe mclovin
can get on this
i am convinced that patrick mahomes
has by far the highest third and long
conversion rate in nfl i mean if they're
all third and seven to third and
fourteen
and he still gets it what is considered
put him in he still does it
what is considered third and long i'd
say
third and seven or more okay some people
say third and six but third and seven or
more
i mean it seems like it's darn near 75
percent dan it's
unbelievable how often
he's able to get that done even a game
where you don't think he plays that
great
22 of 26 couple touchdowns
no interceptions a bunch of third down
conversions with his arm with his legs
i thought that was a really impressive
game overall by
the chiefs how they played defensively
how they ran the ball
because that might be what it's like in
a playoff game
in january in pittsburgh or baltimore
and the chiefs kind of said hey you know
what
we can win that way too yeah that was
really impressive and i think you're
right and i think
you know people look at belichick with
his game plan against the chiefs
even though they couldn't carry it out
because they didn't have cam newton that
night
but if you're going to basically say go
ahead and run we're not going to give
you the deep ball
and we're going to test patrick mahomes
patience and you know maybe we get
a couple of plays maybe we control the
clock on our end and keep him off the
field i think that's what teams are
trying to do whether they're able to be
successful or not
we've got a long season i don't know if
you got to see the cowboys in the
cardinals but
i don't know if it can get much worse
but it's pretty ugly there in dallas
and if you were looking to find a silver
lining here
what would it be oh
i don't know that there is one other
than the fact that unlike previous years
they've been so decimated by injury up
front
on the offensive line that i guess they
at least have a plausible excuse
you know the combination of losing both
tackles the center
now zach martin last night and dak
it's almost like it gives them a reason
for why they're not playing well dan the
truth is though they weren't playing
well
before that the defense has taken a big
step back and i tweeted this
last night at ross tucker nfl this is
why dana i thought it was comical
when everybody acted like this off
season like mike mccarthy was the second
coming of vince lomarti
i mean i think he's a fine coach i'm not
being critical of mccarthy and he's fine
but people made it sound like all off
season
that mike mccarthy's the greatest coach
ever jason garrett's the worst coach
ever
and just because of that one change
garrett out mccarthy in
the cowboys are going to the super bowl
obviously that's not the case
i hate giving a running back a second
contract
i i don't care who it is and and this
isn't you know hindsight here with zeke
elliott i've said it i said it at the
time there is
no way i would have given him that
contract but jerry jones is so desperate
to win another super bowl
that he gave everybody money and it was
like trick or treat when he walked up to
his door
amari cooper here's a hundred uh hey
zeke here's 90 million
demarcus lawrence i want to get paid too
i they just they got some bad
investments there
and these are contracts you just can't
unload
well you certainly can't unload the z
contract and the irony of that
is that of all those guys the guy that
was most important to get locked up for
the long term
was dak prescott the one guy that they
weren't able to get locked up
i'm with you on the running back thing
but i think you look around the league
you know alvin kamara in new orleans
christian mccaffrey and carolina you
know i think that that sounds good dan
and i think from a strictly objective
business standpoint you're right but
when alvin kamara
doesn't show up for practice a couple
days and this is drew brees's last year
you're trying to win the super bowl
what are you going to do when christian
mccaffrey who's by far the face of the
franchise
you know that he's not going to show up
for training camp unless you give him a
contract
i just think it puts these teams in
tough
spots from a on-field standpoint
and the off the field i mean mccaffrey
was the face of the panda i think it's
tough
to hold those guys feet to the fire
you're probably right it's probably not
the best business move
yeah i know like camara i get because of
the importance to drew brees
this year in the saints this year but
he's the he's the only running back
mccaffrey's replacement has matched his
you know
the rushing numbers there you just don't
need these guys they're all
interchangeable it feels like but
uh yeah it's like uh travis etienne at
clemson
is he going to be next year's clyde
edward zelaire
maybe at the end of the first round or
second round you take him
because he's probably just as dynamic as
edward ziller
well and to your point when mike davis
fills in for christian mccaffrey
that well or alexander madison for
dalvin cook
and does a nice job i mean even last
night i thought tony pollard at times
looked better for the cowboys than zeke
elliott
you know these guys are good players
they're deserving of the money
but the backups are usually so
close and so comparable and they're like
third round picks
making the minimum it's very very hard
to justify
financially but i also think it's very
very hard to say
hey thank you for a great three years
we're going to let you play out this
year and then let you go because then
maybe they'll pull a le'veon bell on you
and say hey
i don't want any more tread on the tires
if you're not going to give me what i
want
i'm looking at the background there with
your trophy case you've got
some footballs you got those are the
helmets of all the teams you played for
yeah it looks like uh the washington
throwback
uh in 2002 like the sunny jurgensen
uh arrow helmet then there's not a lot
of
scuff marks on those helmets ross there
are
there's not and there's not oh dan not
youtube
not youtube dan i know about paulie but
not you two
actually there's a lot of scuff marks
because of
practice and trying to make sure i
stayed my butt stayed on the team
so hey hey those game balls they don't
just give those game balls out there
i think they give them out to everybody
apparently um
what are those game balls is there one
that stands out there
yeah so there's four bills ones which
are all cool but the one over this
shoulder
my left shoulder it's a thanksgiving day
game
dallas cowboys so i had started dan
i i've been with the redskins the whole
year midway through the year
spurrier cuts me three i get picked up
on waivers by the cowboys
three weeks later i'm starting on
thanksgiving
against the redskins emmett rushes for a
hundred
we win and you know the deal with
thanksgiving i mean other than the super
bowl i think it's like the most watched
game so
i'm 23 years old start on thanksgiving
we win i fly home the next morning we
get the weekend off
i go to my fifth year high school
reunion dan
that night the day i walked in every
girl that didn't like me
i was like hi stacy how are you hi
jennifer how are you doing
hey how was your thanksgiving what did
you do last night anything you do
anything
see anything on tv yesterday how was it
it was awesome it was like dan if you
said
ross what do you want for your fifth
year reunion i would have said
i don't know maybe i start for the
cowboys the day before that'd be cool
oh have fun giants eagles thursday night
boy that'll be a good one hey whoever
wins has as many wins as anybody
in the uh in the nfc unless it's a tie
again
ross tucker football podcast ah we love
talking to you thank you buddy
all right see you guys all right ross
tucker
former offensive lineman and uh the ross
tucker podcast he works for westwood one
their nfl analyst